la región centroamericana revive el
inicio de la pandemia en guatemala el
repunte de kobe 19 motivó a la
declaración de estado de calamidad
allí el primer mandatario alejandro
giammatei impuso la prohibición de todos
los eventos en masa ya sean educativos
deportivos o religiosos en ese país la
situación desborda los hospitales el 97
por ciento de la capacidad está
comprometida más el sur en costa rica se
registra un incremento de
hospitalizaciones y muertes por kobe 19
de un 21 8% en su vecina nicaragua el
independiente observatorio ciudadano de
kobe 19 pidió a la población
urgentemente realizar una cuarentena
voluntaria para contrarrestar las
consecuencias de eventos masivos
convocados por el gobierno que asegura
que la situación de salud está bajo
control el impacto la inequidad de la
vacunación se refleja en las cifras de
contagios y muertes guatemala costa rica
y panamá lidera en la lista la
organización panamericana de la salud
alertó de un aumento significativo de
casos en la región y calificó de
inaceptable la disparidad entre quienes
pueden acceder a la vacuna y los que no
necesitamos que los países
vacunan tan pronto reciban las vacunas
si bien los países administran las dosis
rápidamente esto es sólo el comienzo a
medida que reciben más dosis y también
envíos más grandes los países deben
asegurar que que los sistemas logísticos
puedan absorber estas dosis y que se
garantice la cadena de frío mientras los
contagios van en aumento y se intenta
seguir le arrastró a la variante delta
en la región guatemala ya registra los
primeros casos de la nueva variante
mundo